Speaker 1: Hey, this is wild. This crazy
Trumpist Republican candidate, Carrie Lake.
She lost it when Fox News's Brett Beyer confronted
her about her hypocrisy on drag queens. Now,
in case you don't know about drag queens, drag
queens are typically we're talking about male
performers who use what's called drag clothing and
makeup to imitate and sometimes even exaggerate
female gender signifiers. But it's entertainment
purposes. Drag queens are not trans people. You
might have trans drag queens, but when we
talk about drag queens, we're talking about
sort of like a performance thing. We're not
talking about transgender people. Okay, fine.
So Carrie Lake has been viciously going after drag
queens and people who enjoy drag queens and all
these different things. And it turns out that a
drag queen came out and said, I've performed for
Carrie Lake. Carrie Lake as hired drag queens to
perform multiple times. She's a hypocrite. Okay.
So she goes on Fox News. Bret Beyer confronts
her. She didn't expect to be confronted about
this on Fox News. And she flips out.
Speaker 4: Says Arizona GOP candidate
who criticized drag queens was once a fan,
according to a drag queen. This is the, quote,
Arizona GOP gubernatorial way.
Speaker 1: It's obviously
so stupid what's going on. But she
is a hypocrite and good for Brett
Beyer for asking her about it.
Speaker 4: And to Carrie Lake,
who has attacked drag queens as dangerous to
children, attended the shows of drag queen Richard
Stephens for more than 20 years and once hired
him to perform at her home in care to address.
Speaker 5: I do care. I actually do care
to address that. And I'm really shocked.
I'm actually appalled.
Speaker 1: That.
Speaker 5: Fox News would take defamatory
story like that. And we are pursuing legal
action against this drag queen.
Speaker 1: Sue the drag queen.
Speaker 5: I'm appalled that you
would bring that up when you have
not talked about our stolen election. You failed.
Speaker 4: Just spent three questions,
just like talking about this issue. Ask you
a number of questions about it. I played
the Arizona. This is the first and let's
address let's address this story that's in
The Washington Post. Every candidate takes tough
stories. I'm asking you to to it. You'd like to.
Speaker 5: I'm happy to address it, but
I'm really disappointed in Fox. I thought
you were a little better than CNN.
Speaker 1: I'm really disappointed.
Speaker 5: This is a person who I covered
for decades, for decades, 20 years,
and he's never been in my home. He says he's been
in my home for a drag show. That's ludicrous. He's
never been in my home. He's lied. We tried to
serve him defamation papers and he's so shady
that we can't even track him down because
he's not even welcome at the place. What?
Speaker 4: To work? I'm sorry, but
this is the last question being asked.
What about these pictures of you with him?
Speaker 3: Isn't that the best? What about the.
Speaker 1: Pictures where you're together?
Speaker 4: Richard Stephens. Randy, what about
this? The post I perform for Carrie's birthday.
I performed in her home, perform for her at some
of the seediest bars in Phenix. I don't want to
ask these questions. I asked you to address them.
Speaker 5: I actually think I think you do
want to ask him, but you don't want to ask
about 2000 mules, right?
Speaker 1: I think Dinesh
D'Souza film, too. That's the real issue.
Speaker 5: Guys do want to ask about this. This
is absolutely ludicrous. And I'm talking about
drag shows in schools. This is what triggered
this man. Somebody who goes to a drag show with
female impersonators is one thing. We don't want
our tax money going into drag shows at school.
Speaker 4: Okay. I understand what you're
saying. You last there, but you're saying his
allegations are wrong, is what you're saying?
Speaker 5: Yes, I am.
Speaker 1: And I'm despite the pictures,
the allegations are completely untrue. Unhinged,
unhinged. And this is what it has come down to,
folks. These people are out of their minds and
they might win in November. If we don't get out
and vote, we'll have these clips on our Instagram.
Find us on Instagram at The David Pakman Show.